This next story is sort of a cross between
sad, hilarious, but also disturbingly emblematic
of the absolute absurdity, not just of this
administration, but of the last seven days
and Trump Landia
or fearless orange leader in the middle of
an impeachment inquiry going formal of being
booed and shouted, lock him up at during a
world series game and his staged post ISIS
raid photo op has been reduced to tweeting
pictures of dogs to put it lightly with inaccurate
claims about the dog.
Take a look at this quote.
We have declassified, a picture of the wonderful
dog named named not declassified, that did
such a great job in capturing and killing
the leader of ISIS, Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
So first of all, is there anything more cringe-worthy
than continuing to tout in the most bizarre
way possible?
This raid over the weekend as if it was Donald
Trump's doing, but then maybe more importantly,
the dog did a good job kept capturing and
killing al-Baghdadi al-Baghdadi died by suicide
at his own doing, using the suicide vest that
he was wearing, killing three of his own children.
In, so doing what on earth is going on here.
And there's actually a lot of sort of weird
dog related imagery, literal and metaphorical.
Donald Trump not only tweeting pictures of
dogs related to the Al Baghdadi raid, but
remember that Donald Trump used the word dog
multiple times during his big speech, the
death of Al Baghdadi to denigrate people calling
them dogs.
When I saw this tweet, what maybe struck me
most viscerally was the, there's a, a realization
I had, I guess that Donald Trump could never
have a dog because he just doesn't really
care about other beings in the way you have
to, to properly care for a dog.
And this really is just a lead up to the bigger
story of all the lies that Donald Trump has
been telling about the death of Abu Bocker.
All Baghdadi, which I'm going to get into
next.
But let me remind you when he, I think this
bears repeating earlier this week, I showed
you a tweet, um, I believe it was on Monday,
where Donald Trump back in 2012 said, listen,
um, why are we criticizing?
Rather, why are we praising Barack Obama so
much for the killing of Osama bin Laden?
It was our service members who did it.
Let's stop praising Barack Obama because Barack
Obama didn't do it.
That same tweet basically tells you everything
you need to know about what is going on this
week.
And the much the same way that when the bar
letter was released in advance of the Mueller
report several months ago, Donald Trump used
the bar letter to justify a national exoneration
and vindication tour, which of us, which of
course was completely an absolutely bogus,
but it worked.
Donald Trump is similarly using this raid
against al-Baghdadi, um, to justify his own
existence essentially, and to Pat himself
on the back in ways that are completely beyond
what the facts dictate.
Now in the next segment, I'm going to get
to what level of credit does Donald Trump
deserve for this?
But first, let's review the lies that Donald
Trump has been telling.